The Internet needs a refresher course on words and what they mean.
And we're here to help.
I don't need no word refreshments.
Yes, you do.
Okay, this one's pretty easy.
Let's start with "they're."
"They're" is a contraction of two words.
So it can only mean one thing: they are.
So if you break the words apart in a sentence and it doesn't make sense,...
...he is going over they are?
Try again.
Okay, so this leaves "there" and "their."
"There" is a place.
Here's an easy way to remember it.
Here, there.
Wait, where?
Yeah, that's a good way to remember it too.
What?
Stop it.
Why?
So the only one left is "their,"...
...which means it's this.
Yeah, think for a second to make sure you're using the right one.
You will learn this in the third grade, dummy!
Don't say that!
Why?